how's it going - and welcome to another
ninja comes the story this one is called
amnesia rain they're telling me the best
experience to play at night alone with
headphones check cure guard made this
one that's the way oh it's another
loading screen you know what that means
right you don't I don't either so let's
just we don't have to make this awkward
every time okay it's it's fine it's fine
if you if it's loading we're just
talking to each other and what how about
you ask me something for once huh how
about that it's all meats doing all that
work what's that what what what I can't
okay I'm sorry I can't I can't hear you
you have to speak up next time kyouda
guard I present this looks a lot like
amnesia the other one I play whoa
like six freakiest huh oh I'm Adam Nisha
cus I'm sorry well no funny [ __ ] okay it
has corridors I don't like this I'm
nature rain
well this looks like a well-made one so
far so good I hope I was loading again
what was how you're going to say before
I didn't really catch that [ __ ] you say
about my mom I'm just kidding dad just
kidding
yep a lot of loadings in this one up mmm
okay have a gun oh you can tell me later
don't worry about it you weren't saying
anything well I can read minds you know
that chapter one dungeons
okay well that's fine well the [ __ ] am i
[ __ ]
last time I drink too much that looked
like someone's girlfriend
hot as hell man hope I can find that
[ __ ] all right there's a note here my
fear my life is in peril someone or
something is keeping me in this cage
against my did I write this oh it is
okay where am I and how would I get
there I have no recollection of for my
memories fragmented and my mind is
scattered I find it necessary to write
down my thoughts for fear of losing them
again I don't know how many times I had
drifted in and out of consciousness or
for how long I have been here I see
vicious beyond this nightmare visions of
wood and carpet instead of stone and
dirt I hear rain and I feel compelled
forth by something beyond my ability to
describe in worth the hole in the center
of this cell looks like the only way out
okay
what what are you [ __ ] up sorry I'm
sorry I didn't catch anything
it's the box the box did it it wasn't me
as a gum
hey box I'm sorry I'm sorry
yep every time pills shut up it's the
first time you liar
whoa but but I get the feeling I should
not be done down here okay so why the
yeah okay why would I write down about
this hole and just not go in there yeah
that kind of a my stupid or am I trying
to protect my I don't like this there's
a little--it DAF king colonic off
comfort all the pink about it Ola Ola
DAF all right this way ladies and bros
frozen girls hey s don't happen I'll
take what the [ __ ] was that
it's water does not splash by itself
don't [ __ ] with me water IIIi know how
to make fire that's right oh you're not
so tough now are you okay I'll just
[ __ ] combine these two and [ __ ]
kill people how about that [ __ ] and by
people I mean walls ah stupid wall
anything I was
ah get away from me stone I'm free it's
a miracle hallelujah
why don't we got here what moving parts
and shed that's the new one okay why
don't we go uh-huh
the mattress lovely I wish I had a
mattress you [ __ ] box
Oh No
calm down what the [ __ ] okay I have a
bad feeling about this room okay let's
go there anyway hello hi it's ER
it's what I do uh okay well hello okay
what are the LAT a wax roll the [ __ ]
laughs what the [ __ ]
okay well that's really good to say
that's what you get your [ __ ] box
what this is where I was in the
beginning this is my my girlfriend red
okay
well that's nice okay who would destroy
an innocent chair that's been shaking in
the dirt prison ah with no memory of the
events that brought me here okay but I
have no memory whatsoever uh-huh these
walls seem familiar though with an angle
entirely lost down here my intuition is
providing me guidance in this matters I
feel sure that I can escape from this
place
well that's good sir I'm gonna exit to
these dungeons through the northern
prison cells the entrance to which is
not far from here the number will fire a
key and this key is fallen into the
bowels of the torture chamber Oh what's
it what's what's a bower what's a bowel
huh you dare me what's a bowel no you
don't want to tell me what the bowel is
well less [ __ ] can I go here oh there's
a torsion area
olynyk confidence is reassuring I feel
overwhelmed by the possibility of my
escape from this matter and so I've been
in prison in these halls for much longer
than I actually have okay so that's why
I left a note that probably sort of pig
at the dining table nice nice
no no no I feel like there's something
blocking well okay
hello lamb oh hello candles
the weather can't really see it though
let's go
that kinda just literally up at itself
you know what bros do you might think
you there's a bad stuff in here but I
say no I say let's go aha let's try and
break it no what
how about this Christmas wax roll oh
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] it at all oh oh look at that
where is your trigger but here's I don't
know where they were Roger Roger where
it don't go they'll never tell you well
die [ __ ] ha ha ha sorry ok well that's
done
now shut everything is gonna rock these
days hey what are you what pipe what are
you doing
I [ __ ] but not nothing nothing
nothing nothing
ok you got a look oh wow Oh what are you
doing there laudanum [ __ ] laudanum
and sleep and [ __ ] what
why don't we got here a bottle not on my
watch that's right yes of course
but no latter night I'm sleeping in the
bed
what a hell in there boulders what is a
boulder oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] down
here give it down here shut up
why do I hear this sound
okay okay this is driving me nuts
oh I found a secret King y'all all right
ah I all I did was click the door whoa
whoa where do you come from
slaggy what's going on here with the
like stop it game thank you uh-huh
Shrek befo be a right there lovely
lovely lovely
I'm not this [ __ ] again what do you why
what stop stop stop it game it's [ __ ]
creepy man I know I don't like this no I
don't Oh
what
you double think of me yo [ __ ] dorsum
ha ha with me [ __ ] shut up it was me
too I'm a leg what shut up ah ah stop
stop stop
Oh a grub encore all right cool I'll
take that
what the [ __ ] hi I'm okay okay okay I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry okay all right
my fine
what why would you try to kill me like
day
- cool oh well watch cow are you doing
whoa it's a party it's a party
that's a party and a yo si yay this cow
is not gay that runs right I think the
best joke I made on my lap jaysis guys
what the [ __ ]
alright well what do you know this place
is [ __ ] oh look more oh hey how's it
going
ok I'll disturb
it's pretty [ __ ] dark a lantern would
would help you know okay so that guy was
like I was trying to do something Oh
latter place not the acid bath is
designed for two acid baths yeah
execution to what not this end is
refrain fun girl I see a connection with
you that is [ __ ] up that is [ __ ] up
share but bet it that's your clutch what
do you know it get it now after
I didn't do it I didn't do it I didn't
do it god damn it
well Yolo oh okay I purchase I would
have to end this episode here it looks
like a great custom story so far but
yeah the really scary